invitez maintenant de ce journal pour
reparler de ce l'un de ces deux
satellites qui se trouvent donc à bord
de cette fusée Ariane Noël Forgeard vous
êtes PDG de Matra défense espace alors
Olivier Loubet le disait donc dans son
reportage au début de ce journal c'est
un satellite qui en fait va servir à
toutes sortes de choses on a parlé des
Jeux Olympiques d'Albertville mais il y
a aussi une partie militaire c'est ce
qu'on appelle une satellite de nouvelles
génération oui vous savez en fait c'est
depuis 1984 que la télévision le
téléphone avec les départements
d'outre-mer les liaisons donnés pour les
entreprises et puis certaines missions
militaires aussi passent par satellite
alors la génération qui a été lancée
ailleurs à ce moment-là arrive
évidemment en fin de vie et il fallait
la renouveler et c'est la raison de
cette nouvelle vénération Télécom 2
alors ça satellite qui est quoi qui est
plus puissant qui sert à plus de choses
qui a plus alors
deux fois plus gros mais qui avec une
masse donc seulement à peine deux fois
supérieure va avoir une capacité de
transmission de données environ 4 fois
supérieur et qui va avoir une durée de
vie d'environ 10 ans comparé à 7 ans à
peu près pour télécommande mais est-ce
que les techniques n'auront pas beaucoup
évolué en disant est-ce qu'il sera pas
rapidement dépassé on sait que c'est un
domaine là où les techniques bougent
beaucoup échangent beaucoup je crois que
quand on compare ce satellite et
l'émission qu'il emporte avec trois
bandes de fréquence différentes par
rapport aux missions homologues des
satellites américains on constate qu'on
a fait un satellite tout à fait tout à
fait tout bête alors il y a une partie
militaire importante donc il a été
financé en partie par le ministère de la
défense sur le même satellite il y en a
donc une fonction qui coin de
communication télécommunication
militaire et financier à 40% par le
ministère de la Défense il emporte qu'on
appelle la mission Syracuse c'est-à-dire
c'est une mission qui va permettre aux
autorités gouvernementales françaises de
communiquer en temps réel avec des
sous-marins en plongée des bateaux de
surface ou bien déterminaux mobiles sur
des théâtres d'opération d'ailleurs dès
la crise du golf Syracuse 1 son
prédécesseur a été utilisé dans les
mêmes conditions un dernier mot sur ce
secteur des du club des constructeurs de
satellites vous n'êtes pas quand même un
très grand nombre en Europe je crois 5
fabricants en Europe est-ce qu'il y a
des regroupements prévus on parle de
rapprochement de différents fabricants
oui vous savez c'est la loi du marché
qui commande alors dans ce domaine un
seul grand constructeur américain domine
pratiquement la moitié du marché mondial
est-ce que nous devons faire l'Union
Européen c'est nous organiser pour
pouvoir faire face faire face au plan
des technologies et des coûts alors nous
avons engagé chez Matra ces opérations
européennes on nous regroupant il y a
environ 2 ans avec la société
britannique GEC Marconi pour fonder une
compagnie Matra Marconi space
du côté d'autres partenaires qui
partagent les mêmes valeurs que nous
c'est à dire la volonté de créer une
grande compagnie européenne compétitive